hey I'm Justine if you don't know me hi
how are you I've been making videos on
the internet for an extremely long time
I've been on YouTube since 2006 I've
been creating content
ever since my content obviously has
evolved a lot since 2006 are you in a
studio no I'm just in a small little
room but I kind of turned into my office
about 10 years ago I started this little
thing called a vlog University welcome
to vlog University it's a school for
vloggers what's that you don't like
school
vlog University is not a school at all
each week they'll be various challenges
or topics that I'm gonna give to you
guys to inspire you to start creating
our videos originally I wanted it to be
something where I would teach you guys
something that I learned that we you
guys would then take that thing that I
taught you create a video and I would
highlight them in next week's video the
best part about this was the community
you guys are creating fun videos I was
interacting with you and I was getting
to see some of the amazing inspiring
things you guys were making each week so
now 10 years later we decided to reboot
vlog university but rebooted in a really
massive way not just here online but an
actual real life conference we've been
working on this for over a year so the
event is happening January 31st and
February 1st at a Los Angeles Convention
Center well the best things about this
event is I partnered with FMC and
they're the company that puts on so many
amazing incredible conferences all
around the world most notably at AV
which is held in Las Vegas so I could
not have partnered with somebody better
to help bring this entire vision to life
I'm sure the first thing in your mind is
just see what type of event is this is
this like a fan meetup look what are we
gonna be doing here I want people to
come here who want to learn how to
create people who want to learn how to
edit who want to learn more about
branding who want to just learn for me
when I first started doing this stuff
there was nothing there were zero
resources camera equipment was so
expensive I had no one to really look up
to so it was so difficult because I kind
of was just doing things maybe not doing
them correctly learning along the way
making so many mistakes and it's amazing
to see the resources now that are
available so I basically wanted to just
jam pack all of this information into a
two day event so everything that you see
on the website right now which is vlog
University com it's still is tentative
we're still working on the schedule but
this will give you kind of an idea of
the structure and the instructors that
we do have our
credible like the people that we have
are not just people who just learn final
cut last week they've been doing this
stuff their entire life much like I have
been doing what I've been doing almost
my entire life like we want to give you
the best possible instruction I'm still
working on figuring out who we want to
have as some other guest speakers we'll
have some fun panels but really this is
something that we want to give to you
guys so that you can leave this event
feeling inspired and that is the most
difficult thing about this whole process
I have been doing this for an extremely
long time and one of the questions that
people asked how have you managed to
keep going do this for so long and still
manage to sort of reinvent yourself and
I will tell you that it is such a
process there have been so many ups and
downs in this industry of creating
YouTube videos and I remember when we
were calling this new media and at this
point it is the now and something else
that I'm excited about is the future
there's so much new technology with live
streaming and 360 and 180 and 3d but
that's something that I'm also looking
forward to exploring as well so if you
are interested in attending or you want
more information I will put a link in
the description it's log University com
I can't believe that I'm actually
getting to put this domain to use I
bought this over 10 years ago like this
is so amazing to bring this all around
and to have a 10 year anniversary of
vlog university be in 2020 it's gonna be
awesome
I have a discount code if you want to
use that at checkout I just intend go
get 10% off and if you register before
December 31st you'll get a free t-shirt
there's a bunch of packages on the
website so check that out and again if
you have any questions at all feel free
to ask me and if I don't get back to you
quick enough there's a little chat box
on the website meeting feel free to ask
them any questions there this is gonna
be so much fun and honestly if you are a
content creator if you're an aspiring
content creator if you have a job
somewhere that requires you to create
content go to your boss and say I need
to go to this event I really wanted this
to span kind of every aspect of creating
from marketing to branding lighting
editing contract my managers actually
gonna be doing some sessions too so he's
amazing guitar are you guys have
probably seen into my videos in the past
so it's gonna be really cool because
it's basically my entire team is coming
here and you're offering up all of this
information things that we have learned
over the course of very
I mean I remember posting my first
youtube video I didn't know what I was
doing I was just posting things because
I wanted to just create I wanted to make
funny videos and I honestly was just
teaching myself to edit which is the
crazy thing because I start a major
channel because I wanted to learn to
edit in Final Cut but I just wanted to
thank you guys for making all of this
possible and that's what I really wanted
to do is have an event where we could
give back where we can create content
together I'll be leading a bunch of
sessions about marketing about strategy
about branding about creating mobile
videos so just know that we have amazing
people teaching all of these things and
I look forward to seeing you guys so
again the event is here in Los Angeles
at the Convention Center on January 31st
and February 1st
check out vlog University com to learn
more I can't believe log University is a
thing I mean 10 years ago I would have
had no idea that this would be something
that it is now and that's one of the
lessons that I will leave you guys with
you never know what little thing that
you're working on right now just end up
being something that you never would
have expected I look forward to seeing
you guys at flog University mostly
because the next generation of content
creators like it's gonna be you guys you
might be watching this you've never
created a video yet one of these days
maybe that is something that you want to
do and I want to leave you guys with the
best tools to get started and I want you
to be able to make this internet a
better place make meaningful content
something that everyone can enjoy and
just take a little piece of that
negativity and just get it out of there
I'll see you guys later I'm gonna go out
at this video now so
[Music]